>> Tucker: MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN SPENT, TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
OUR ATTENTION HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON NOT OF ACTUAL MATTERS OF
STATED OF SIGNIFICANT BUT ON THE
COLLUSION STORY THAT SWUNG THE
2016 ELECTION.
NOW WE FOUND OUT THE PERSON AT
THE CENTER OF THIS, THE RUSH
LAWYER, HAS NEVER BEEN
INTERVIEWED.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THE INVESTIGATION?
WE HAVE A U.S. ATTORNEY HERE
FROM THE DIRECT OF COLUMBIA.
I DON'T HAVE ANY ESOTERIC
INFORMATION.
SHE DOES
SHE DOE
SHE SAE
SHE SAYS
SHE SAYS S
SHE SAYS SHE
SHE SAYS SHE'S
SHE SAYS SHE'S N
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT B
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT BEE
SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT BEEN
INTERVIEWED.
WHAT DO THAT TELL US?
>> THAT THE INVESTIGATION HAS
BEEN A FRAUD.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
COLLUSION.
MR. COMEY KNEW THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
HE KNEW THERE WAS NO BASIS FOR
ANY OF THE FISA WARRANTS.
THERE WERE NO FOREIGN AGENTS
INVOLVED IN THE CASE FROM THE
BEGINNING AND THAT'S WHY HE
REFUSED TO BRIEF THE GANG OF
EIGHT ON CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE RUSSIAN PROBE
AND THE DOSSIER FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
HE KNEW IF HE BRIEFED THEM, HE
WOULD HAVE TO ANSWER SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BASIS FOR
THE INVESTIGATION, AND NO BASIS
EXISTED.
>> Tucker: JUST AS A PROCEDURAL
MATTER, CAN THE FBI DIRECTOR SAY
NO TO CONGRESS WHEN THEY SAY
COME TELL US ABOUT SOMETHING,
CAN HE SAY NO?
>> HE KEPT IT FROM THEM.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THE RUSSIAN
PROBE, THE COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
PROBE EXISTED.
HE KEPT IT FROM THEM.
IF THEY HAD ASKED THEM, HE
CLEARLY WOULD HAVE LIED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE HE'S LIED ABOUT IT EVER
SINCE THE OPPORTUNITY AROSE.
HE UNFORTUNATELY WAS CONFRONTED
BY THE EXISTENCE OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE FAILURE TO
DISCLOSE IT BY A CONGRESSWOMAN
DURING THE INVESTIGATION WHEN
THE WHOLE THING BLEW UP.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
I WOULD THINK BOTH PARTIES --
DEMOCRATS THINK THEY TAKE
CONTROL OF THE GOVERNMENT AND
THEY MAY.
THEY HAVE AN INTEREST IN HAVING
AN FBI THAT WE CAN TRUST AND WE
CAN ALL TRUST.
SO WHY IS NOBODY ON THE LEFT
CALLING FOR CHARGES TO BE FILED
AGAINST THE FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI WHO
ACCORDING TO THE I.G. LIED?
ISN'T THAT PERJURY?
WOULDN'T THAT WARRANT A
PROSECUTION?
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT McCABE
WILL BE PROSECUTED.
WHETHER OR NOT REMAINS WILL BE
SEEN.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO.
NOW THAT THEY CHARGELE MICHAEL
FLYNN WITH LYING AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND ALL OF THESE
LITTLE PEOPLE THAT HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG.
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN'T CHARGE
ANDREW McCABE.
REMEMBER, HE'S A SENIOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL, SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL.
LIED UNDER OATH THREE TIMES.
NO WAY HE CAN'T BE CHARGED WITH
LYING.
>> Tucker: THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN BE CERTAIN WHEN THE
I.G. OF THE FBI ISSUES ITS
REPORT THAT WE CAN TRUST THAT,
RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT
THAT MR. HOROWITZ HAS DONE A
CREDIBLE JOB.
NO REASON TO DOUBT HIM.
IN ADDITION, THE INTERNAL WATCH
DOGS OF THE FBI THEMSELVES,
THEIR OWN OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, THEIR ETHICS
WATCH DOGS, SAID THAT HE LIED TO
THEM.
>> SO IF YOU HAVE A SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL THAT LIED
UNDER OATH, REPEATEDLY ABOUT A
CRIMINAL MATTER, WHY WOULD HE BE
DEFENDED BY LIBERALS?
WHERE ARE THE CIVIL LIBERTARIANS
ON THE LEFT?
>> BECAUSE THE LIBERALS ARE NOT
LIBERALS.
THEY'RE PROGRESSIVES.
THEY CREATED THE HORRIBLE
MOVEMENTS IN THE 20s AND 30s.
THOSE PEOPLE NO LONGER THINK.
THEY'RE REACTING.
THEY'RE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HATE HIM.
THERE'S NO MORE PRINCIPLES.
THEY BELIEVE EVERYTHING SHOULD
BE SACRIFICED FOR THE THRILL OF
HAVING POWER AND DOING WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO DO TO SHOVE DOWN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE'S THROAT.
THEY HAVE ABANDONED ALL PRETENSE
IN BELIEVING IN FREE SPEECH,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, THEY HAVE BECOME PROPONENTS
OF THE FBI BEING AN ORGANIZATION
THAT LIES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THEY SENT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TO A SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL THAT WAS
FIRED FOR LYING UNDER OATH AND
THE LEFT IS SUPPORTING IT.
>> THEY ARE SUPPORTING IT
BECAUSE THEY HATE THIS PRESIDENT
SO MUCH THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE THE CONSTITUTION AND
ANY CORE BELIEFS THAT YOU HAVE
AS A REAL LIBERAL.